this world cup is unifying the Arab
world
with Morocco the first ever Muslim
Nation to reach the quarterfinals the
first time football's biggest event has
come to the region
it's a platform Sky News understands
some officials in Qatar wanted to use to
raise awareness of discrimination faced
by Muslim people
we've obtained images showing no place
for islamophobia armbands featuring a
Palestinian headscarf pattern
we're told officials in the World Cup
host nation talked about them with other
countries including Saudi Arabia and
Morocco but a senior Qatari official
says they were told by FIFA the armbands
would violate kit regulations
FIFA claims not to be aware of any
proposal but made no one available for
interview they do think that this is one
of the biggest issues they are facing
now universally the islamophobia in the
same event or any other mega event is
organized in any other part of the world
you have the local agenda somehow
highlighted a dispute over one lover
armbands dominated the build-up to the
World Cup
FIFA threatened punishments if england
and Wales joined others in wearing them
to subtly draw attention to qatar's
anti-lgbt laws
FIFA counted the proposal for one of
armbands with more generic
anti-discrimination messaging while
talking about using the power of
football to make a positive impact on
society FIFA has dissuaded direct
activism and unequivocal messages like
no to islamophobia
it's a missed opportunity for some fans
what people think about Islam is pretty
bad around the world so it's actually
something nice that people actually
change their thought change their
thoughts and think that it's actually
something better and it's not what they
think as what they see in the social
media and the news so I think it was a
perfect idea this is the best way to
keep everything just focused on the
whole sport you know we're here to watch
the game we're here to enjoy our time to
for people to come along and like
despite the differences going around in
the world you're just having a good time
watching the match watching a World Cup
providing a positive platform for Muslim
fans away from the islamophobia suffered
elsewhere
Rob Harris Sky News Doha